[Musique]
à
m
bienvenue dans cette émission spéciale
en partenariat avec yveline disney ce
club qui est représentée par son
président laurent garbe à merci pour
l'invitation
bonjour vous êtes vous êtes aussi le
président de trianon échangeurs et on
aura l'occasion d'en parler puisque dans
cette émission va donner la parole à des
dirigeants justement pour voir quelles
ont été leurs attitudes pendant cette
crise de l'aco vide et on va voir qui
lui beaucoup d'innovations que tu étais
sur deux défaites on en reparlera
évidemment avec vous tout à l'heure et
puis françois bouziane bonjour bonjour
et vous êtes le manager in business club
et dans cette émission en effet où on va
voir comment les entreprises peuvent
rebondir et et comment elle prépare la
reprise de la préco vilain ce thème ne
cessez de vous avez ça et sont tous deux
en fait de transformer et de créer de la
valeur dans cette zone compliquée il ya
beaucoup de choses à faire à partir du
moment on réinvente la façon de voir les
choses et le la chance justement d'être
connecté en réseau
l'opportunité d'être membre d'un club
d'un club d'affaires en fait c'est
vraiment de favoriser les rencontres
on va voir d'ailleurs il ya des
rencontres qui s'est sans doute à leurs
fruits
évidemment
il distingue ce club c'est beaucoup de
justement de rencontres que vous
organisé dans une période comme celle là
c'est évidemment beaucoup plus difficile
on a pu rencontrer mais on a quand même
parce que on a créé cette synergie
depuis quelques mois quelques années on
est un club jeanne malgré tout on a créé
du lien
déjà on a déjà des relations entre nous
et ça c'est cevital en ce moment parce
qu'on on est en pertes de relations
aussi bien avec nos collaborateurs avec
le télétravail et on a besoin d'échanger
on a besoin de trouver des bons plans
comme je dis souvent des opportunités et
ce qui est extraordinaire avec un un
club comme ils disent c'est tout de
suite on est que cette synergie et on
échange énormément entre nous tu reçois
dans l'opérationnel ou de façon plus
informelle
c'est plus nécessaire que j'avais
exactement ça révèle vraiment le fait
que nous sommes des êtres vielles à la
société donc on ne vit qu'avec les
autres donc évidemment nous organisons
des visions des choses à distance oui le
et le club continue continue de vivre
pas et par contre comme je reprend les
termes de laurent c'est que nous c'est
vraiment orienté autour de la
convivialité
ce sont des dirigeants des chefs
d'entreprise qui trouvent des valeurs
communes et y trouve des affinités
il n'y a aucune pression les relations
se font vraiment au gré des rencontres
et comme l'exprimé laurent ce qui est
très important c'est d'avoir créé cette
confiance à partir du mans la confiance
est en place or cette confiance ne peut
vraiment l'installer que caen se
rencontrent donc là nous profitons à
travers les 50 plus de 50 membres
existants
justement des relations qui ont été
tissés il a on peut les valoriser quand
les temps sont plus difficiles
justement leurs regards jeudi vous êtes
pd2 triano échangés c'est important
aussi dans cette période où on ya un
risque de repli sur soi de savoir ce que
font les autres comment ils réagissent
et qu'elle est aussi qu'elle leur état
d'esprit mais peut-être l'état de
leur situation économique c'est très
important parce qu'on n'est pas du tout
dans les mêmes situations
oui mais on est sur des secteurs très
différents et c'est cette
pluridisciplinarité de des métiers qu'on
retrouve dans le club qui nous permet de
rencontrer un assureur rencontré une
société informatique et c'est vrai qu'on
a cette possibilité de d'échanger avec
un dirigeant qui se rend compte qu'ils
rencontrent les mêmes problématiques que
nous en particulier à une nouvelle
organisation du travail
on en parlera tout à l'heure et avoir
sept retours d'expérience on se voit je
rencontre des dirigeants on est sur un
une zone
on est très proches les uns des autres
donc on se rencontre en présentiel ça
aussi c'est important et on échange
entre entre nous sur plein de sujets
mais ça peut être le sujet économique
parce que on a des difficultés de
trésorerie mais c'est un sujet que
s'élabore très très souvent et il ya
plein de solutions
j'échange beaucoup avec les échanges et
les dirigeants sur les solutions qui
sont mises en place
et parce que des solutions comme il y en
a heureusement il y en a plein et
justement parce qu'on va peut-être
parler du fonctionnement des lycées ce
club pendant cette panne mais au delà en
effet c'est vrai que c'est un club c'est
aussi des liens qu'on a tissé avant et
qu'ils ont
il ya évidemment la réunion mais même en
dehors des réunions voilà ça s'appelait
aux besoins de ce que je connais quoi
c'est ça ce thème ça et puis il ya une
dimension qui avec les formes dans notre
club c'est que habituellement donc nous
nous c'est les événements sont
essentiellement autour de déjeuner ceci
permettant au chef donc là il ya plus de
belzébuth déjeuner et skis c'est très
important aussi c'est qu'habituellement
on à l'apport de personnalités
extérieures
donc ça qu'ils sont des bulles d'oxygène
d d d envoi de dynamique très très forte
donc là on les retrouve par des visions
c'est pas la même chose
donc ce qui est très important c'est
d'avoir c'est de valoriser aujourd'hui
ce réseau ces échanges
donc les personnes se rencontrent ça
plus petits groupes évidemment donc nous
favorisons des rencontres serrées
quelques personnes qui se rencontrent
dans chacune des entreprises et qui
peuvent valoriser sur les thématiques
très forte
l'idée et je pense aujourd'hui de cette
émission c'est de montrer des pistes
pour les gens qui peut écouter
il ya des choses à faire sur des sujets
habituellement repoussent à plus tard
c'est le moment de le faire et il ya
vraiment cette possibilité là et les
entreprises qui vont pouvoir le faire
qu'ils vont jouer le jeu où on vraiment
pouvoir démarrer beaucoup plus vite au
moment du feu vert exactement
et c'est parce qu'elle de ya toujours
deux tendances possibles via le repli
sur soi ce genre de situation où yahoo
l'ouverture et au fond ce que vous
prenez prenez-vous c'est l'ouverture
ces rencontres et vous essayez de
trouver des solutions ensemble c'est sûr
regardez pour les autres on est face à
des nouvelles problématiques
on va en parler aussi la cyber
criminalité
non pas mais il faut trouver des clients
on a quand même des clients qui sont en
difficulté on en parlait tout à l'heure
c'est difficile de conclure aujourd'hui
en un contrat en distance yale ça on se
rend compte que c'est plus facile de
conclure en présentiel évidemment mais
on cherche des solutions là on a des
besoins des besoins de ressources
humaines de je disais tout à l'heure de
de besoin de trésorerie et on cherche et
se ces échanges nous permet de
s'échanger ses solutions et on trouve
aussi les compétences dans lequel j'ai
trouvé des compétences en informatique
je disais non les assurances et c'est un
élément très important par rapport à
cybercriminalité puisqu'il va falloir
s'assurer le plus vite possible au
niveau des pme parce qu'on est devenu
une cible on va le voir tout à l'heure
c'est pas juste des choses qu'on voit
dans les jours on a un spécialiste puis
on a un spécialiste de l'automobile mon
mât chercher les véhicules on a j'en ai
trouvé dans le club on a la chance
d'avoir élevé de se retrouver à trouver
des solutions très intéressante et
économique
donc il ya beaucoup de synergies et ça
fait quand même 50 % des membres du club
sont des chefs d'entreprises liées soit
ment de l'industrie ou du btp dont il ya
aussi des gens qui trouvent de la
sous-traitance et ce qui est fondamental
également dans cette période
c'est soit le repli comme vous le
précisez vatry ce soit le repli soit
l'ouverture nous vraiment une preuve
d'ouverture et donc de communiquer de
faire savoir
parce que c'est vraiment les entreprises
qui vont faire savoir faire connaître
leur savoir faire qui vont sortir du lot
leurs vents donner quelques exemples
oui on dans cette division le regarde on
va se retrouver tout à l'heure pour
parler avec vous de tri yann aux
échangeurs fonds soit vous y reviendrez
à la fin de cette émission pour lui
voilà pour la coqueluche et on va
commencer par justement l'expérience de
deux chefs d'entreprises qui sont
rencontrés grâce à evelyne disais ce
club et qui ont travaillé ensemble
pendant cette période c'est thierry de
maires de l'agglo concept et puis c'est
antoine goulard denis des pis
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
alors on va commencer par une première à
prouver récit de rénovation novation
dans l'entreprise avec thierry lumière
bonjour vous êtes le pdg de l'eau clos
concept et antoine blin bonjour zenger
denis des pistes qui est une agence de
communication
alors on va raconter ce qu est ce que
vous avez fait ensemble mais votre
rencontre s'est séparé yvelines business
club à l'origine oui bien sûr alors moi
je suis arrivé dans le 118 ya eu
relativement peu de temps que j'ai
repris une entreprise y a deux ans avec
une obligation de changement de nom là
bas on va parler parce que l'entreprise
s'appelait leur établissement le cloarec
absolument et effectué une entreprise
qui fait des cuisines industrielles
c'est absolument qui les entretient est
qui et qui les installe donc c'était une
second établissement le cloarec il
existait depuis 57 ans 57 ans et avec
une bonne odeur idée excellente
notoriété mais avec une obligation
contractuelle de changer le nom à savoir
et la façon d'atterrir au club c'était
simplement moi je me suis un an 78 je
connaissais pas grand monde
on est un peu isolé en tant que chef
d'entreprise l'idée c'est de trouver un
club de dirigeants et de pouvoir
échanger
comment dit tout à l'heure sur bouziane
et donc j'ai trouvé le livre d'une
business club par le réseau entreprendre
et j'ai rencontré une première fois
antoine goulard qui a fait une
présentation de son entreprise
denis dp alors
quand elodie des plaintes l'édifice est
une agence conseil en communication et
design conseil communication et design
c'est bien mettre les 3 serbe est au
coeur de notre métier l'accompagnement
humain et c'est ce qu'on retrouve aussi
les binômes isoscope design qui veut
dire quoi ça veut dire design c'est à
dire qu'aujourd'hui on travaille sur le
design global
on a peut accompagner pour donner un
exemple concret un promoteur immobilier
de sa réflexion âgées un grand vide à
vendre au plus tard ça va être créée sur
l'identité visuelle son logo son site
internet sa stratégie de vente est aussi
le design d'intérieur de ces immeubles
de ses appartements haut de ses
restaurants la conduit en accompagnant
un certain nombre de clients sur la
globalité
voilà la globalité du design un mot sur
les agences de communication pendant
cette période c'est compliqué parce que
l'on dit parfois que c'est bien c'est là
dessus que les entreprises vont
peut-être alors c'est le premier sujet
sur lequel on coupe
mais c'est aussi parfois le premier
sujet qu'on va aussi remettre en marche
aujourd'hui on a eu un frein clair
al'annonce du couvre-feu et du
confinement derrière des gens ont
commencé à venir
on parlait de communication tout à
l'heure on parlait de d'ouverture mais
moi j'ai positionné lagence une
ouverture optimiste et donc dans notre
façon de communiquer on est et on
sortait d'anxiogène on a été dans une
communication très anxiogène pendant que
le confinement et nous on a eu
particulier de dire non on peut faire
des choses bien il faut préparer
l'avenir donc n'attendons pas la sortie
pour se préparer n'attendons pas la
sortie pour parler positivement étiez
lemière leur dit il y avait cette
obligation contractuelle allait changer
de nom mais est ce que finalement vous
êtes diba cette période la cg peut-être
un peu plus de temps j'en sais rien pour
réfléchir à l'avenir de mon entreprise
et je vais en profiter
situation est exactement ça c'est que
dans un premier temps la reprise
d'entreprise il fallait balayer tous les
sujets et la remettre au goût du jour à
mon image le nom faisait partie les
couleurs également y compris l'
architecture intérieure parce que j'ai
dans cet état de profiter pour refaire
tous les travaux intérieurs donc avec un
risque bien sûr d'investissement mais
pour le personnel ça s'imposait de les
mettre dans des locaux neufs et le nom
forcément il fallait trouver quelque
chose qui soit qui tarde un peu
l'histoire de deux ya des histoires
simples modernes et le cloarec est
devenu le clou c'est alors ils ont
regardé la racine pourquoi parce que le
mal mais c'est ccni d'épicés au travers
l'autre vous le premier lien c'est il y
avait le clos de dents parce que le clos
c'est le surnom de l'entreprise et tout
le monde disait on va c'est le clos
absolument dans les bureaux d'études
c'était cette racine et après j'ai eu
une écoute assez intéressante de la part
d'antoine on s'est vus de trois heures
on a échangé sur plein de choses et il a
capté les goûts les couleurs et j'avoue
qu'il m'a rendu quelque chose très très
vite et très peu un entonnoir très serré
et dedans j'ai trouvé tout de suite que
ce que je voulais c'est quoi les codes
comme ça d'une visite industrielle
aujourd'hui justement nous le parti pris
de l'agencé toujours d un peu en décalé
par rapport aux autres
donc il veut de la modernité il voulait
quelque chose de dynamique
quand on a parlé du nom on a travaillé
ensemble parce que moi je considère
qu'on est là pour les accompagner et les
conseiller mais on n'a pas la science
infuse
donc c'est le résultat de l'udc le
concept c'est un travailleur entre eux
et nous i
donc voilà donc le but après c'est qu'on
construit ce qu'on les écoute et
qu'après les avoir écoutés on se dise
voilà les concurrents font ça comment se
différencier par rapport aux donc on
sort un peu des codes de la cuisine et
c'est une volonté de ne pas ré qui a été
acceptée par repartirait ensuite et pour
vos clients
vous avez déjà des retours j'ai de très
bons retours
le même sens sans même demander un on a
des gens qui nous ont même appelé en
disant on a vu votre design c'est ça
montre une rénovation d'entreprise
salaire très dynamique et donc on a
quelques clients qui viennent nous voir
et puis le retour des clients actifs qui
nous ont dit que c'étaient vraiment des
superbes couleurs
elle arrive elle touche de green aussi
dedans pour l'environnement hier les à
la notion qu'on veut donner aussi une
envie les cures dans le présent bien sûr
une nouvelle ère en angola comment était
la période et c'est vrai que c'était
probablement pour plus difficile que
d'habitude même si vous arrivez vous
travaillez à continuer la période est
posée la période était difficile oui
mais on a quand même bien travaillé
bientôt la période qui va arriver qui
peut être plus difficile parce que des
gens ce qu'on creuse et solaire et dans
la danse exaucé puisque vous on peut le
voir à l'écran aujourd'hui on a eu des
créneaux c'était ont communiqué avec
humour et pédagogie et en créant des
liens donc on a différents clients qui
sont nulles voire des chaînes d'hôtels
qui nous offre là là il faut faire des
affiches avec plein de pictos pour faire
peur pour expliquer aux gens que tout ce
qui se passe mais à force de voir des
buts ou plus picto donc on enterrait est
ce que vous nous autoriser à faire ce
qu'on veut dans le nuit de raisonnable
et alors a créé une énorme affiche qui
représentait une maison de poupée et
sans perçu que les gens qui venaient
s'arrêter dans la fiche et les et
concernant ce qui se passait dans
l'hôtel
donc c'est des petites choses un peu
différentes qui sortent du lot les
restaurants jour qui voulait annoncer la
réouverture
il voulait mettre qu'ils utilisaient des
masques des gants mettre tout ça en gros
nous on a décidé de mettre un escrimeur
à l'astronaute et un chevalier procédé
petit côté décalé qui permet de dire
allez un peu d'humour alors qu'il n'en a
besoin
et voilà donc mais c'est pour ça
qu'aujourd'hui de nous on n'a pas été
touché dans un premier temps après on
perd ce que donne parce que on a gardé
des liens notamment grâce au club qui a
une énergie
même que positive on s'appelait thiery
ont séparé françois ans n'est pas d'être
lent avec vanessa rousso valeur donc
c'est des gens avec qui on phosphore on
échange qui pour parfois refaire des
impressions des uns ou des autres
c'est vraiment très agréable et vous
tirez lumière la période et comment un
an les difficiles parce qu'on va devoir
faire un bilan dix mois le 12 donc
forcément ça pose des problèmes et il
faut il faut se réinventer il faut
trouver des solutions
ma première préoccupation c'était de
trouver du travail pour tout le monde
donc on a réappris la polyvalence dans
l'entreprise savoir faire muter des gens
sur d'autres métiers léger mais pour
occuper tout le monde est aujourd'hui on
a personne au chômage technique ce qui
est une prouesse depuis dix mois à celle
ci a mené vers la tour personne les a eu
deux mois au début comme tout le monde
mais depuis dix mois
tout le monde travaille on est même on a
beaucoup de travail donc on continue et
la rénovation de nos entreprises c'est
justement vous cette période là vous a
poussé ou là on disait 1 700 rénovation
au fond est-ce que derrick période qui
est évidemment difficile à affronter
c'est un peu comme quand on est au fond
de la piscine là c'est le moment de
donner moi je sais que ça m'a galvanisé
par ce que c'est un permis de de poser
un peu tout et de dire il faut profiter
de ce temps un peu mort pour remettre
tout à niveau et être prêt pour le
rebond et moi j'attends le rebond très
vite
j'espère que c'est dans les quelques
semaines qui suivent mais au moins on
sera près partout on aura des locaux
prêts à recevoir des gens si on a besoin
d'embaucher on sera près partout partout
c'est 9 de parts ou là comme l'intérieur
l'extérieur les voitures tout est prêt
donc on attend ce rebond avec impatience
avec impatience bas-côté bravo et
croiser les doigts évidemment parce que
comme comme vous le disiez
antoine goulard les conséquences de la
situation va les voir dans plutôt dans
quelques mois c'est là que ça c'est la
vérité vraie cette fois et c'est pour ça
que tu as une bonne démarche de dire il
faut se préparer à ça pour avoir les
outils pour même nom l' agence de
communication dans ce créneau outils
pendant la période de re léger
ralentissement au mois d'avril pour
pouvoir communiquer efficacement
derrière très bien la jument version va
parler d'une autre histoire
maintenant on va parler de formation
avec vanessa louvel on va parler de
l'informatique cybersécurité avec
emmanuel gaude fond et puis et puis
aussi de d'écologie avec laurent garma
merci à tous les deuxièmes
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
alors à parler de trois autres domaines
de formation avec vous valez sa nouvelle
de vous êtes de skill for all 1
c'est comme ça qu'on dit le cap sur
lequel il faut dire fort parce que sinon
ça marche pas il faut le dire comme on
le dit en anglais avec on va voir les
d'informatique de cybersécurité avec
édouard bonnefont deux infinis link
emmanuel oui un film j'ai dit quoi il
doit avoir non manuel les manuels
bonnefont cm3 oui bonjour d'infini bing
et puis leur engagement avec vous on va
parler d'environnement et de télétravail
parce que c'est très important dans la
suivante en période alors on va
commencer avec vanessa fauvel ce qu'il
faut ce qu'il faut rôle c'est de
l'information numérique ce qu'on appelle
du digital learning en français en
faction en digital learning et nous
sommes spécialisés dans l'information
certes chante à forte valeur pour les
métiers de l'informatique les français
ou particulièrement gestion projet en
agilité en transformation dit d'accord
et votre spécificité c'est que
vous accompagnez les gens qui font la
formation chez vous jusqu'au bout oui
absolument
c'était intéressant d'intervenir
aujourd'hui sur votre plaque sur la
reprise parce que lorsqu'on parle de
mots prise de croissance de performances
vont pense pas il immédiatement à la
formation comme t'y es par me or quand
on va chercher de la croissance il faut
se démarquer de ses concurrents et pour
ça il ya nécessairement l'obligation
d'être dans l'excellence opérationnelle
et 5
la montée en compétence des
collaborateurs le permet après il faut
aussi se focaliser sur ses activités son
coeur de métier et pour ça la formation
elle doit être rapide et elle doit
s'adapter au rythme de travail de
l'entreprise et le fait que nous soyons
par exemple digitale de remous ça permet
de démarrer une formation et le
lendemain de l'accord et va se caler sur
le rythme d'une entreprise qui peut être
un peu en retrait pendant le bolide ou
qui peut être justement focaliser sur
d'autres sujets qui n'a pas beaucoup de
temps
d'accord qui sort qui sont vos étudiants
employés ce bout d'os ils viennent et
des gens qui veulent changer de 2010 qui
veulent se perfectionner
y aller où il ya des deux groupes
tentent d'ailleurs à thiais de tous sont
des formations certifiantes
internationale et qui ont une grande
expertise sur un certain nombre de
métiers dont la plupart des gens qui se
passe chez nous ce sont des laboratoires
avec depuis longtemps et qui ont envie
soit de creuser leur domaine d expertise
soit allé le diversifier l'idée étant
vraiment d'aller chercher un niveau de
compétence qui est valorisable pour le
client final et du coup de filet pour
les formations sur de quelle durée
c'est très variable d'une manière
générale vous êtes sûr on va parler en
est parce qu on va mener sur delabel
question autant travail et bien
ces mines et les informations globales
sur un an bonheur dizaine une vingtaine
et une cinquantaine d'heures pour les
milliers ou les sujets et évidemment
alors c'est évidemment un secteur
portant on en parlera avec emmanuel
bonnes chauffes redoutable mais les gens
qui viennent chez vous alors souvent
c'est des gens qui et qui c'est qui
restent dans leur entreprise ou qui
cherchent un autre emploi ces variables
en fait d'une manière générale petite
information permet de beaucoup de
conserver les talents en interne
la plupart du temps la réponse on ce
sont des gens en tout cas quand
l'entreprise va financer cette formation
l'entreprise va pouvoir conserver ses
talents est allé chercher d'autres
territoires ses clients et du coup elle
met en face une formation qui va être un
frein valeur qui va permettre justement
20/09/10 et des collaborateurs et de
fermenter aussi en compétence qui est
vite allé faire du grand rex il veut
disiez tout à l'heure et je voudrais
voir le sentiment de laurent ggagbo là
dessus mais c'est vrai dans une
situation qui va être difficile hors jeu
on va avoir probablement une montée du
chômage
la formation la formation
professionnelle c'est un des ressorts
essentiels
c'est très important c'est très
important le
il ya eu un effort les du gouvernement
pour aider l'apprentissage nous les
entreprises on a pris trois apprentis
tout de suite ccc l'occasion de former
des jeunes et on a besoin de former des
gens mais on sait nouvelle organisation
nécessite également de monter comme dit
vanessa en compétences nos
collaborateurs et et cette transition
sera possible si on arrive nous pme
parce qu'on on n'a pas beaucoup de
budget malheureusement b il faut faut
faire cet effort de formation de notre
personnel pour monter en capacité sur
des nouveaux métiers et le numérique
génère nouveau métier on travaille dans
les échangeurs mais il ya énormément de
besoins dieu c est un secteur qui par
chance est très porteur pour pour
l'emploi van bommel juste un bol une
formation certifiante ça veut dire quoi
ça veut dire qu'elle corresponde oui
meilleures pratiques sur le marché ou le
secteur concerné vous travaillez dans la
g de sucre projet là le moyen que vous
avez de pouvoir attester de votre niveau
soit votre expérience soit le diplôme
que dans quelques mois lorsque vous
arrivez avec une certes une
certification et bien sale temps gillis
totalement votre employabilité parce que
comme ce sont des normes et ce sont des
standards internationaux
une autre entreprise lorsque vous êtes
certifié dans tel domaine est en
capacité de savoir quel est votre niveau
et que vous embauchez a compris et
surtout à la bonne mission d'accord donc
oui donc c'est fondamental le regard bas
alors parlons un peu de deux trianon et
songeur parce que là aussi nous sommes
jeudi un peu dans l'air du temps c'est
vrai ce sont si j'ai bien compris un des
échangeurs thermiques
il s'agit de récupérer tout ce qu'ils
sont consommés de transformer en énergie
c'est ça on aimerait bien on aimerait
bien saison passée d'état c'est notre
métier métier si notre métier en une
entreprise familiale
cas plus de 20 ans 1 oui mon père a fait
ses premiers calculs qui est ingénieur
en génie thermique à 50/50 rendu compte
de ça on a un savoir faire en france
même en sein d'une tpe on est vraiment
une pme de 10 personnes à versailles
mais on a un savoir faire incroyable
notre métier c'est de concevoir des
échangeurs sur mesure ou récupérateur
chaleur pour les installer dans
l'industrie le besoin est immense
puisqu'on est dans cette logique de
transition énergétique et est en plein
dedans au départ on travaille dans le
tertiaire dans le secteur dans la
climatisation
aujourd'hui notre développement il va
vers la récupération de chaleur sur les
fumées industrielles et le besoin est
énorme et il ya des solutions simples on
est pas on n'invente pas des de la haute
technologie
mais il faut savoir faire des calculs et
en france on est on à cette connaissance
cette ingénierie et j'ai cinq ingénieurs
on a cette capacité à dimensionner et on
est reconnu pour ça et autres avec des
grands comptes et on travaille dans le
nucléaire dans la navale des gens des
grands comptes passe par nous parce
qu'ils sont ils ont besoin de
performances et et technologie et on
connaît ces technologies de récupération
pour donner un exemple un gros
industriel français nous a consultés
pour récupérer la charte sur ces fumées
la 58e dans le monde et on a conçu des
échangeurs en france qui vont être
fabriqués en suisse pour une société
française qui va l'installer en chine et
on va récupérer sur ces échangeurs on
récupère des quantités
incroyable d'énergie on parle de 2
mégawatts ses lacets venir c'est
l'avenir c'est l'avenir est ce que le
plan de relance qui insiste justement
sur la transition écologique vous aide
pas encore puisque plan de relance il et
il n'est pas il vient il vient il ya pas
eu beaucoup d'être sur l'industrie on
est sur le plus tôt le bâtiment le plan
de relance et est vraiment s'orienter
sur le bâtiment sur une belle saison
c'est relativement facile vers des
relations il faut isoler nous on est on
est dans le process industriel et dans
la récupération de faire des
l'optimisation des flux alors que le
plan avance vraiment et c'est tout à
fait nécessaire avant de récupérer il
faut déjà isolé donc ses premiers
premières obligations pendant cette
période évidemment le télétravail a été
fondamental ça vous a aidé beaucoup
beaucoup de vous seriez fait était vital
c'est l'état est vital c'était vital on
a eu la chance de passer à une mutation
numérique en 2017
pourquoi parce que j'avais un de mes
salariés qui avaient un projet de vie
d'aller vivre à chambéry
et ça m'a interpellé gilles mais il faut
qu'on faut qu'on soit capable de
travailler avec des du personnel qui
soit ya quelques années avant d'arriver
à chambéry burns a changé et il a fait
et en 2017
on avait nos dossiers papier on est
passé en tout numérique avec un serveur
externe partage de données travail
collaboratif grâce à des logiciels ont
été aidés par la chambre de commerce à
l'époque et en 2018 est parti à chambéry
et c'est un ingénieur il y travaille au
quotidien avec les autres collaborateurs
de l'entreprise
et quand arrive et le confinement nous
on était prêts donc tous mes
collaborateurs sont partis en
télétravail
j'ai pas fait de chômage partiel et le
passé et on a un chiffre d'affaires qui
est supérieur en 2020 que 2019 on a eu
on a cette chance d'être multi
sectorielle aussi on aurait trahi key
que l'aéronautique n'ont pas été bien le
fait de travailler dominateurs dès cet
été mais le
l'outil était là l'organisation se sait
vous l'avez un peu penser à vous aussi
ce qui fait que vous étiez équipe et
c'est pour ça qu'aujourd'hui il faut il
faut urgemment
mais les entreprises l'ont compris il ya
dû y avoir certains chefs d'entreprise
une petite scepticisme sur le
télétravail en désordre et finalement on
s'aperçoit que ça marche tout très bien
quoi au départ on est on est inquiet en
vérité la vie mais pour faire ce qu'ils
travaillent g1
j'ai fait une mission drh dans mon
entreprise j'ai pas de brèche mais j'ai
une mission externe et café une
rencontre et les salariés et c'est ce
qui ressort de 2,7 de cette étude rh et
qu' ils sont globalement satisfaits
voire très satisfaits puisqu'ils veulent
y rester
est ce qui est extraordinaire c'est que
j'ai deux autres salariés qui vient de
partir une à nice et l'otan ont flambé
dames c'est vous la et donc de la part
des candidatures de yassa posé près
organisationnel donc il ya besoin quand
même de se voir pour lui il faut pas
faut pas dire que le télétravail est une
solution travail surtout à 100% est une
solution il ment ça que ça génère un
manque de relation et un perte une perte
du lien
ils essaient tout l'enjeu managériale
c'est de garder ce lien à distance
regardait aussi là le coeur y être on
s'est planté devant n'a pas besoin
d'être ensemble
l'un des symboles injuste au relais les
formations elles se font actuellement
elles se font sur site ou à ceux peuvent
se faire aussi par le
en visio parle de travail enfin notre
spécial nous c'est comme ça qu'on allons
accompagner mon essence en digital c'est
pour ça qu'on a pu vraiment accompagné
de mon à gries du couvent idée encore
les entreprises à ce que les formations
étaient accessibles immédiatement et on
était déjà routiniers en fait pour faire
tous les juges et la montage en plus de
tous digitale qui les rends compte c'est
que finalement vous êtes une fille plus
mépris de formation que vous n'avez pas
ces coûts de structure voulait fait
d'économiser gagnant ou quand vous êtes
dans une optimisation du caire même si
la formation il faut tailler non j'ai là
les merlus sont intéressants parce que
c'est fort mais j'ai appris
ok merci beaucoup à vous entendez un
petit peu moins bien
malheureusement à la fin de votre propos
emmanuel bonnefont alors parlé d'un fini
link qui se spécialise dans
l'installation de systèmes informatiques
et la digitalisation des entreprises
notamment des pme
évidemment la lal période on parlait de
télétravail comme on regarde pas la
période est favorable pour ce pour 7 des
utilisations notamment des entreprises
elle est très favorable effectivement on
voit ça fait déjà plusieurs années que
je fais partie de lévis minimiser ce
club et donc
c'est c'est un moyen aussi d'échanger et
de de pouvoir partager avec les membres
du réseau
alors quand on pouvait encore se
rencontrer physiquement même si
aujourd'hui il ya encore des sessions
qui sont fait à distance mais c'est vrai
que l'année 2020 est l'année de
confinement qu on a vécu ça a été pour
nous un moyen de faire de la croissance
assez forte puisque on fait 20 % de
croissance sur l'année quoi quelles sont
les grandes demandes qui nous on vote
alors aujourd'hui les grandes demandes
elles sont dans alors le télétravail
gestion de l'utilisateur nomade
je vais pas dire vraiment le télétravail
c'est vraiment gestion l'utilisateur
nomade parce que ce qu'on peut comparer
aux devoirs aujourd'hui oui
effectivement c'est que on a des gens
qui vont faire du télétravail pendant un
jour deux jours après il peut y avoir
des réunions qui sont organisées dans
les entreprises à 3 4 personnes où ils
vont se retrouver sur des des plateaux
de travail pas oublié comment dans
l'entreprise mais aller ce temps là et
ensuite peut-être une fois par semaine
ils vont se retrouver à l'entreprise
pour justement garder ce lien et les
utilisateurs les collaborateurs sont
demandeurs de ça donc on va travailler
sur les solutions de nomadisme et de
sécurisation
parce que c'est un enjeu c'est un prêt
c'est un fléau je dirais depuis déjà
plusieurs années
et là les entreprises les entrepreneurs
on a vraiment pris conscience du
gouvernement d'ailleurs assortie à un
projet assez fort là dessus alors n'est
pas notre boulot de cybersécurité parce
que on avait vu doigt comme ça on a
l'impression que sur get que les très
grosses entreprises que cdd peut-être
parfois des pays qui sont derrière tout
ça et c'est peut-être ça d'ailleurs un b
les pme sont aussi affectés par pas
recette
oui c'est à tout cas cybersécurité
clairement aujourd'hui tout le monde est
confronté à ce type de problème il n'y a
pas une seule personne n'y a pas même un
un auto entrepreneur peut être confronté
à ça bien sûr alors on entend beaucoup
parler effectivement des attaques qui
viennent des pays gérait extérieur sur
des grosses attaques ou là s'est préparé
à l'avant sur des très grosses
entreprises où il va y avoir de la fuite
d'informations mais ça c'est c'est
simplement lui dire l'iceberg la partie
visible de l'iceberg
en fait tout le reste c'est toutes les
attaques qui peut y avoir dans les pme
les tpe françaises aujourd'hui où les
dirigeants ne communique pas sur ces
attaques et et donc ils peuvent enfin
ils sont vraiment impacté de manière
très forte et ce qu'on voit aujourd'hui
c'est que il ya 9 entreprises sur 10 qui
ne se remettent pas d'une cyberattaque
ci se sont pas préparés à ça il se passe
comment ces îles sont ainsi souvent en
fait aujourd'hui le premier lien de da
taxe et le son appel et crypto locker où
il va y avoir un mail qui va arriver qui
va crypter les données on va faire du
chantage à la rançon et le deuxième
c'est on en parlait tout à l'heure c'est
la tacc président larnack au président
lula
et oui alors le télétravail c'est
extraordinaire oui je crois qu'il n'est
fait avec une entreprise de transport
oui résulat raconté alors je sais que
j'ai des clients qui a été heureusement
ils ont su s'y prendre
je dirais de manière assez pro
activistes s'en sont aperçus très
rapidement ils sont ils ont subi aussi
ce type de ce type d' attaque où il ya
une société qui s'est fait passer auprès
d'eux
la direction financière en comme le
président avec usurpation du numéro
téléphone communication et demande de
virement bombail comme ils étaient
préparés ils ont effectivement réussi à
bloquer les virements et à pas les
fermer
c'est très bien fait ouais c'était très
bien fait et très bien fait et c'est un
des vrais oui c'est vrai problème est
bien pourvu qu'on va rencontrer de plus
en plus de plus en plus
en fait pour qu'il ya des bars dont un
avec un fini dink est justement il ya
déjà des moyens de se prémunir des
attaques
alors la question ce n'est pas de savoir
est-ce que je vais être confronté à ce
type de problème la question c'est quand
donc c'est quand et comment et comment
est ce que je vais réagir mal grâce à
donc pour ce prêt pour se prémunir en
tout cas pour se préparer à ce type de
problématique
il va falloir d'abord identifier les
points de faiblesse dans l'entreprise
avec de la communication auprès des
utilisateurs avec alors tout à l'heure
on parlait de formation on va faire la
sensibilisation plus exactement auprès
des collaborateurs
ensuite on va mettre en place des
solutions de protection que ce soit des
protections de protection physique ou
aussi logiciel sur les postes avec des
antilles ransomware des logiciels qui
permet de détecter ces attaques
lorsqu'on les a détectés après c'est
comment est-ce qu'on réagit donc faire
des plans de reprise d'activité
mettre en place des solutions qui vont
permettre de redémarrer plus ou moins
rapidement
alors il ya des entreprises qui vont
avoir besoin de redémarrer en 15 minutes
d'autres qui m'ont dire non mais c'est
bon ainsi droit des marques demain matin
c'est pas grave
et donc on va mesurer tout ça on va
définir le plan d'action et ensuite
c'est la remise en production de la
solution dont vraiment nous on va
intervenir sur l'ensemble du périmètre
de sur la partie informatique et
télécoms sur les gir et la protection la
communication et la remise en production
des infrastructures
si super des je suis victime d'un
sondage
votre conseil c'est quoi à mon premier
conseil c'est d'aller sur le site de
l'insee où il sur les sites pour aller
regarder les partenaires les plus
proches de chez vous allez porter
plainte et bien sûr auprès de l'agent de
2,8 involys et et première chose aussi à
faire évidemment avant tout ça le
premier geste c'est débrancher les
ordinateurs et les serveurs coupé
l'informatique complètement et faire
appel à des spécialistes
à écouter merci infiniment emmanuel
bonnefont merci beaucoup aux
connaisseurs ovale merci laurent garbe
avoue rester avec moi on va appeler
françois que vous y avez puis on va
conclure cette émission merci beaucoup
merci à vous
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
voilà de retour sur ce plateau avec le
regard d'un président in business club
et françois bouziane des yvelines dsk
évidemment manager de ville quel
business club c'est voilà c'était assez
passionnant les témoignages qu'on a eus
vous avez regardé procréation est ce que
laurent était avec moi sur le plateau
d'un conte c'est plus compliqué donne je
vais jouer mais c'est qu'est ce que vous
retenez au fond pour moi c'est vraiment
l'illustration parfaite de la de la
richesse des rencontres et j'en tire
aussi une conclusion que je que je me
faisais c'est ce qui a été dit à
plusieurs reprises s'ouvrir et vraiment
c'est le fait le maître mot en ce moment
attention repli passait vraiment
l'ouverture maximale se faire aider
trouver des compétences ailleurs et pour
ça donc il faut connaître les gens et
avoir confiance et pour moi le médium
parfait c'est vraiment le réseau qui
permet de rencontrer les gens comprendre
la compétence de l'autre et pouvoir
faire appel quand c'est le moment et
nous l'avons vu sur des thématiques
extrêmement actuelle primordial comme la
digitalisation aujourd'hui c'est
incontournable est bon pour ça il faut
avoir dans son dans son univers des
personnes compétentes et pas hésité à se
faire aider et on l'a vu a des liens
avec les participants ces plateaux qui
sont dans des secteurs différents mais
qui ce que vs tout ce qu'ils savent ce
que font les autres qui sauve comme en
italie
c'est important c'est important de se
connaître
moi je suis très étonné je vendais on
est sur une niche de marché pour des
échanges dynamiques et un nouveau membre
récent nous a demandé d'optimiser son
datacenter à vélizy veut avoir une
nouvelle technologie datacenter immergé
à très faible consommation énergétique
et dans par le hasard de la discussion
il s'est rendu compte qu'on était un
même club et et tout de suite ça crée
cette synergie et on va être appelé à
optimiser son process énergétique au
départ quand je suis arrivé aux légumes
des ce que je pensais pas
trouver un client même de faire cette
spécificité massif c'est possible et on
sait l'ensemble des compétences qui sont
globalisés
mais ça c'est très important et très
intéressant de pouvoir bénéficier des
expériences de chacun surtout dans une
période de transition où les besoins
sont nouveaux et nous chefs d'entreprise
on n'est pas compétent dans tous donc
c'est c'est ce partage d'informations se
partage de compétences qui font que nous
on monte en puissance et le dirigeant
qui restent derrière son bureau dans
sont opérationnels il passera pas la
crise il va y valant lure comme on dit
il faut sortir les gens qui sont
absentés revenir nous voir parce que je
raconte emmanuel d'autres vont par
exemple sur les cyberattaques est là il
faut être
voilà qui ont aussi on reste chez soi on
est pas on n'est pas prêt de ce genre de
choses il y avoue ballet du mot
d'ouverture françois boulianne ya
peut-être un autre mot qui est important
celui de confiance tout à faire pour la
confiance parfois l'aphorisme français
qui dit que ça se mérite
on n'est pas loin de ça en tout cas
c'est ça se donne pas de manière comme
ça spontanée
nous notre vision au sein du club c'est
d'abord la convivialité
alors évidemment en ce moment la
dimension conviviale elle est compliquée
nous ne recevons pas des on a l'habitude
de recevoir des gens avec eux je dirais
un humanisme vraiment hyper dynamisant
des dernières personnes qu'on a
rencontrée c'est nelson monfort regrets
mais c'est très bien donc là on
retardant sa journée avec une dose
d'optimisme et de dynamisme qui nous
fait bien il faut dire voilà vous avez
mon ami tu es très variés ça va outre
exemple bon extrêmement fin vraiment
avec une dimension émotionnelle qui a
été très très forte
on a reçu jérôme kerviel mais elle était
un moment d'émotion dans la salle qui
était le rendu était là je pensais
vraiment max est une
on sentait qu'il avait vécu une un
traumatisme et se partage de son émotion
de son expérience et ses difficultés
ça nous renvoie toujours aussi à à nos
difficultés c'est pas de show même
niveau mais c'est cette expérience qui
nous fait grandir et qui qui nous qui
génère chez nous un espèce de 1
on sort de ces réunions et ces échanges
plus en plus confiant plus fort plus
fort mais on en a besoin parce que c'est
dur c'est dur nous on est là pour gérer
mais c'est difficile
la période difficile et anxiogène donc
on a besoin de se rencontrer et de
rencontrer des gens qui sont une
démarche positive et qui nous rêver
nerfs c'est le chef d'entreprise c'est
ça c'est un sportif de très haut niveau
avec dans une période comme ça il faut
de la moquée qui est galvaudé en ce
moment mais qui est vraiment très
significatif c'est la résilience
il faut faire preuve d'une résilience
énorme pour soi pour les autres parce
qu'ils vont entraîner tout le monde et
je me souviens également d'un nos
témoignages fabuleuse c'est christopher
pratt qui a fait plusieurs
transatlantiques et qui nous raconte son
naufrage
et comment il a survécu comment il a
sauvé sa vie et comment on fait derrière
et en plus c'est un chef d'entreprise
terre comment on fait aussi pour monter
un budget pour faire une siens en
fin de course
ce sont des leçons qui permette aux gens
à chaque fois mais oui ça veut dire
qu'on peut retirer à chaque fois quelque
chose de soi même
olivier moreau un marcheur qui il à la
traverser l'australie premier concours
en entrant 1400 km 34 jours j'ai lu son
livre j'ai discuté avec lui je continue
à le voir il m'a donné un optimisme sans
avenir et c'était une rencontre
personnellement et professionnellement
très importante pour moi et ça m'aide
pour prendre les bonnes décisions
aujourd'hui on peut pas dire en
confiance parce qu'on n'est pas le
seigneur un certain 2001 savait
difficile c'est difficile 2021 oui doit
se cacher sa l'édifice
les aides vont baisser ça va pas être
facile mais ça n'empêche que il faut
investir faut faut aller dans la
transition dans le changement et on
puise l'optimiste de chacun ou la bonne
idée ou la bonne compétence et c'est ce
qui nous permet d'avancer
ne pas rester seul vous vous espérez
pour reprendre les conférences de livrer
ce pub avant la naissance avec filiation
la programmation est prête la ligue et
personne ne sait de clausade je sais que
si je fais la semaine prochaine ne
baisse que ce que nous pouvons dire
l'ajc la préparation c'est que nous
sommes prêts
dans la programmation nous allons avoir
la chance de recevoir
laurent brunet requis et le directeur
général louis de formule 1 exactement
plus le domaine synergie vraiment énorme
à trouver avec beaucoup avec des chefs
d'entreprise ayant exactement donc là
y'a de la finale j à trouver nous avons
reprogrammé camille lacourt parce que
nous tenons à avoir des sportifs de haut
niveau et de très haut niveau pour
septembre
donc voilà la préservation est prête on
attend que top départ
et puis ce sur quoi nous allons
travailler dans les semaines qui
arrivent
ce sont sur des micro rencontre en
respectant tous les protocoles six chefs
d'entreprise qui se rend compte dans
l'entreprise de chacun un bon continuer
à avoir le lien
en plus ceux visités dans l'entreprise
de l'audi donc on va le faire dans ce
que nous permet actuellement les les
contraintes sanitaires faut admirer
quelques mais joint en sorte riffs pas
ainsi on va croiser les doigts
effectivement merci beaucoup le
regardeur france merci grc rivlin
business club il ya un site évidemment
oui yvelise lescop simplement taper sur
n'importe quel moteur de recherche
exactement
merci beaucoup ricco et à très bientôt
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]